la chance d'avoir également julien
castaldi fils d'un très grand animal
est mort pour le plus pour moi le plus
grand benjamin castaldi bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes influenceurs également alors
on vous voit vous ça y est vous avez
pris le même chemin que votre père un
mois non mais ça on voulait faire de la
télé font surtout c'était vrai nom que
son père que votre père pas spécialement
non je suis quand même un peu tu as
envie d'être voilà tu as envie de faire
quand même de petits crèvent dans la
lumière alors alors justement pas trop
trop j'essaye de je me suis rendu compte
tu sais j'ai fait énergie il s'attarde
pas plus avec fiona ça m'a plus
humainement c'est chaque fois que les
gens font un truc axonais qui sont pas
content non
ohlala non ça m'a plus humainement c'est
une expérience incroyable qui fiona
houle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mad max était une expérience de
dingue j'ai toujours rêvé tue c'est de
montrer un match à 10h30 moi je préfére
j'ai toujours préféré le mc mario matt
et un bref voilà c'est une super
expérience mais ça va ma montrer que
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas ta came
sais pas si c'est pas là où je suis bien
c'est pas là où je suis julien poueys tu
étais petit écart tt castaldi à
l'antenne
eilat et julien quoi voilà beaucoup plus
non mais ça quand tu es en dehors des
plateaux qui joue bien mais quand tu
rentres sur un plateau et castaldi et
c'est exactement ce qu'ils préfèrent
être julien que castaldi tout à fait pas
je te comprends
est ce que toi tu as eu des moments
difficiles où est-ce que ça a été facile
d'être le papa de l'office de bâches
bleues pas parce qu'on est plus mature
que lui c'est non mais c'est ça et non
mais
difficile quand tu es petit tu as la
critique des enfants de toutes les
façons donc genre coalisant me disais
watts on s'en fout ton père ivoirien
tout ça
[Rires]
lui en fait encore une cote à 1 6 2 et
que et que tu es et que tes enfants en
plus sur temps vous sur le souvent les
enfants ils sont conseillés par leurs
parents donc deux sur des propos qui ne
sont pas si ça donc ils entendent un
truc couette avec le nom mais c'est vrai
que tu sur moi je suis sûr que mes
enfants aidés en aiguille acteurs avec
le compte de la mise à la france est
donc en fait ils te sortent des produits
qui viennent walser bouchons qui sont
beaucoup plus blessants parce que je
suis était petit tu comprends pas été
blessés parfois oui j'ai été blessé
plusieurs fois en plus j'avais pas
physiquement j'étais pas j'étais pas au
top donc tu vois tu le dois tout un peu
le reflet de ton père fait qu'il
connaisse pas donc donc je prie j'en ai
pris pour mon c'est dur ça ma pomme
c'est bien julien quand j'étais petit il
y avait il avait évité les verts
presqu'au baisse doit pas sortir
c'est là c'est toujours sabres avec vous
ouais ça dépasse julien quand ils
étaient obèses vraiment ces gars là on
met et donc il a beaucoup souffert et
après c'est vrai que le lui là le pauvre
il quand j'ai pas manqué d'exploser
cette église de lofts et moi je peux
même plus venir chercher à l'école
c'était pas possible ils venaient ils
venaient en chapeau en cagoule avec le
garde du corps j'en suis une
exfiltration de l'école tu ne connais
pas tu pourrais je me faisais enlevé
genre ça sérieusement il venait
j'ai en train de décider
mais se
rendaient pas service était le leur
franchement c'était c'était un truc de
légende et emma bol non messieurs a déjà
entendu des trucs qui tombe laissés sur
ton père ah oui le pire c'est tu sais il
ya un moment il avait fait un article
j'étais pas au courant ce que j'étais en
internat où il pensait mettre fin à ses
fins m mais mettre fin à sa vie tu vois
et du coup les gens sont venus me voir
en disant tu sais que ton père a projeté
de danse lumière et tout donc quand tu
es en interne a accepté dans un attentat
c'est que la zone et que tu entends ça
tu leur dis maintenant n'importe quoi
elle est arrêtée bêtise et on a un deux
cinq dix quinze les profs julien tu es
sûr que ça va on a lu la presse je peux
voir la presse et ils m'ont montré le la
presse où mon père me disait qu'il était
utile était pas bien et tout alors je
sais pas et je lui dis on m avait invité
je lui ai je lui avais dit il ya un
article si si il y avait là aussi il ya
eu un fait une presse où tu disais que
tu voulais
j'aurais plusieurs et au pire et voilà
que tu pense au pire mais les gens tu
sais comme ils sont quand tu dis je
pensais tu vas donc voilà ça c'était le
vraiment la partie la plus même vous
soyez vue
[Rires]
je m'en rends pas compte c'est
franchement ça me blesse c'est vrai que
le projet pop rock quand j'ai dit
répondu c'est de conneries la victime
pas du tout pensé mais d'assurance pour
faire baisser non pas du tout c'est pas
du tout pensé j'imagine mal à se désoler
voilà c'est non mais il n'y a pas de
souci il ya prescription et puis on a
rattrapé sata idée quand même à être le
fils de benjamin parce que tu nous l'as
dit que ce test nous a dit que tu ailles
pas plus mais il de rien je pense que ça
a été aussi pour intégrer la télévision
ah oui alors pour attirer la télévision
ceinture oui j'ai eu j'ai eu un vip pass
éméché par casting on était une dizaine
de palestiniens était très beau julien
je lui demande si c'est vrai que mina
non monsieur les vérités moi c'est
pareil bougeait pas et c'est pareil pour
moi quand même de trucs et âme à
m'engager gta question c'est vrai bien
qu'il engagé et il m'a pris pour faire
le cinéma il avait les gants parole
notamment s'élèvent dans le cinéma donc
pour lui c'était voilà c'était c'était
utile mais ça vous aviez du talon aussi
bien pour le piston on en a tous les
niveaux on a toujours un petit coup de
piston qu'on soit dans voilà charcutier
ce qui est embêtant c'est quand on reste
alors qu'on n'est pas bon et pour le
coup julien était très bon mais il est
temps il s'adresse télévision voilà j'ai
voulu me prouver que je pouvais en fait
je voulais montrer à mon père tu t'es
con quand est pas bien dans ta peau que
t'as pas vu beaucoup ton père que tu te
rapproches de lui et plus tard dans il
eu droit hier moi aussi je peux faire
donc j'ai fait ça pendant un an c'était
extra j'ai rencontré des gens
formidables guillaume fiona ier mais
c'étaient des personnes vraiment qui
monte qui monte qui m'ont aidé à après
gap en fait fi n'est finalement que ce
n'était pas fait pour moi et que et que
voilà je serais beaucoup plus heureux
sans essayer de me caler une vie qui
n'est pas la mienne en fait je pourrais
tu peut pas égaler ce qui ce qui la fait
tu peux pas et donc voilà je n'en voyais
pas faire de la télé réalité dure
d'égaler ce que vous avez fait serrer
benjamin s'est tu t'imagines 16 millions
de téléspectateurs ccc ccc que cinq
femmes
vous savez ce qu'il a refusé pour le
coup alors ça a été incroyable deux fois
s'il a refusé de faire ces crêtes il
devait rentrer comme ça mais comme comme
secret mon père et mon père et le père
de la télé-réalité c'est sans la refuser
de le faire deux fois ont ils m'ont
appelé mais toutes les téléréalités -
appelée et imaginez-vous il sait qu'il
ya eu la même chose avec isabelle mal a
failli rentrer mon père et le père de
l'humanité
je les ai vus contre le créateur
éditorial sans rigoler
et mais jour d'hui je te sens alors
ouais je sais pas si je le sens italie
oui on dirait que ça il tâte perd match
il a réglé c'est quoi aujourd'hui ttec
une meuf t'a tekton je suis fiancée
prochaine ce sera toi
calcina coq et syna
mais sur quoi tu y vas oui j'aimerais
bien marier l'année prochaine tu
choisirais jardin des lutins ou la
version vous pouvez jeter invités pour
le même n'est pas venu mais je peux vous
rajoutez pas m'échauffer jamais au
mariage de rêve alors il faut bien
tout va bien maintenant mais ça oui moi
je voudrais j'ai un modèle tu vois on va
dire que c'est pas l'exemple parfait
pour les les mariages long termiste mon
père mais mais persiste oui il qu'ils
vont très très loin ou qui durera en
fait j'ai vraiment un modèle un peu
idyllique du mariage j'aimerais avoir
une femme pour toute ma vie je les
trouvais je me fous c'est trop mignon
sport
c'est bon elle lui que la dore il est
extraordinaire et la tamouls je suis pas
hamas appelle comment s'appelle chiara
chara ouais
ouais une allemande
n'en seriez vous la connaissez très bien
bien sûr et ferment à ses seins et lé
père spéciaux des cantons la niche est
présenté mon père alors étrangement
c'est aussi alors pas dans le milieu
médias mais c'est aussi une fille de
personnes assez importante dans un autre
secteur c'est que sinon que c'est
d'accord voilà dans un autre secteur
donc il y avait pas s'il n'y avait pas
ces quarts à qui ces garçons de famille
c'est très rassurant la fille de william
non non non
elle voilà elle la famille valachie kibo
dans une enseigne d'ameublement traite a
reconnu électroménager boum boum
choisissez bien sûr
les idées de génie à quoi les aînés
c'est pas vrai mais si quoi son père
c'est non non maintenant j'aurais bien
aimé ta laurent gerra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais la belle fille donc capable ce
truc de comme quand j'étais sur l'a12 où
les nanas l année a à foison sur les
réseaux et avec comme seul intérêt de de
côtoyer un fils de là c'était vraiment
hyper hyper sain quoi
m